and then home improvement comes to line
tim this is brand new you've never seen
it before i didn't audition for it i
mean they just came in they said
we want you to start tomorrow well come
here give me a hug
what did you think of the show i didn't
know anything they called me and they
said there's this guy
he's a stand-up he did this show it
wasn't an award i never heard of him
that is a man's dishwasher
immediately i loved him tim i want you
now
everything that we dealt with in terms
of marriage and family and kids
and really oh we're just sort of classic
ongoing deals it still works today it
does
not he wanted that show to go on forever
and they said let's do it with dead jill
and then tim was like
i i don't think we can do that i am so
glad that i didn't let anybody talk me
out of marrying you
so then he went out and said oh i think
it's time to end home and proof
we're going to cover it all i want to go
back to the beginning because people
need to remember you're a broadway
actress
truly really you're from theater i went
to smu
and i had very serious theater training
and
before i went to new york what was it
like getting to broadway
my first audition was for arthur
lawrence on gypsy
yeah and i didn't know what i was doing
and i was auditioning for louise
who doesn't know what she's doing
louise's gypsy and so i was a complete
idiot
and terrified i mean it was a whole
whole thing was a disaster
everything i did they thought was
hilarious and they were on the floor
laughing because i was so nervous and
awkward and stupid
and so i got the part isn't that a crazy
way to start your car
like you you just show up in new york
you get a broadway role and it's like
one of the biggest broadway shows of all
time it's fantastic and we've had the
role of the chinese waitress you know
the one who notices that she's stealing
the
silverware and so i got to do a big
double take and it got me my commercial
agents
and by this point i just had henry my
first child
and i was so excited about henry i
actually really kind of changed all my
values really when i had my first child
i think i had been over invested
invested
in my career and i had henry
i was so in love with henry and by this
point in my career i realized i wasn't
going to be meryl streep
and i was like well you know this is
fine
i i i do some commercials to keep my you
know money going
tv stuff started getting that's what i
was gonna say and the first one was a
norman lear show
called double trouble it wasn't
successful and i came back and that's
when i did
best play the second play i did of hers
the miss firecracker contest
and it was so fun so what led up to home
improvement
i start doing sitcoms yeah every sitcom
i do goes to 13 and dies
right you know it's like can't catch a
break right so
then i'm thinking about trying to have
and we start are talking about
do we really want henry to be an only
child i don't
i you know so we thought let's give
henry a brother or sister so
three years i try again to get pregnant
finally get pregnant and it's
oh man high risk bad things go wrong i
actually have them three weeks early
i have 15 pounds worth of babies they're
annoying you know they're fine they're
okay they're a little early but they're
fine
i go through three months i'm so happy
we're both so happy everybody's so happy
and then home improvement comes along
and i didn't audition for it i mean they
just came in they said
we want you to start tomorrow and come
in and replace somebody
who turns out to be francis fisher who's
now my good friend
this is the greatest gift you've ever
given me i gave you three children
yeah but none of them came out this
clean what did you think of the show
i didn't know anything they called me
and they said there's this guy he's a
stand-up did he did this show it wanted
an award on showtime i've never heard of
him a great another should come
around the family it's gonna fail
whatever i am not they had me under
contract at disney
didn't want to do any more sitcoms and i
certainly didn't want to be a thankless
mom i'd never done a thankless mom part
and i didn't want to do another sitcom
because those are so hard and so i'd
been signed to do
a half hour um dramedy
done by carol black and neil marlin you
know the people that did wonder years
one day they just call me and they say
we've decided to cancel home movies that
was going to be the name of it
because but we want you tomorrow to
start in this other show called home
improvement
i'm like what would you do one time just
think they think
no i said i don't want to do it sitcom
and it's a plan mother i don't want to
play a mother now
we got that and that that one no this
one was gonna be okay because it was
gonna
you know it was kind of unusual and they
said well
if you do this one if it doesn't get
picked up in may we'll let you out of
contract right then
so you were really just doing this
you're like okay i'll do this one run
i did it for the money and to get out
totally
they said we will pay you another pilot
fee and we'll let you out in may if it
doesn't go if it
you know if you don't do it otherwise
then we're just we're canceling the
other show and we'll just hold you until
the symbol
you want to groove with me so they tell
you to get there tomorrow
they said well we'll send you a script
and you look at the script and we'll
send you a tape of this guy this comic
of what he did when he got the ace award
so they sent me the script and ray and i
had a thing that ray and i
had both done so many sitcoms right now
ray had done a bunch i've done a bunch
we have a one-page test and and it's
really pretty
dependable on sitcoms you just open the
script anywhere
on any page and if they're just going
for jokes you can tell right away on one
page
if they're telling a story and they're
developing characters
you can tell that on one page as well
we open up a page we look at the one
page and we go oh
they're developing characters and
telling a story so we went well that's
okay they passed the one page test so
then we start with the two of us we read
the script it was like
this is a really good script and i found
out that the writers
had developed were the originators of
roseanne which was my favorite show
wow i loved roseanne i adored roseanne
i as a as a wife and mother myself
i loved her honestly i loved her
frankness
i loved how she didn't have to be
perfect i hated the whole concept of the
perfect sitcom
wife and i loved that she
didn't have to be this little perfect
yeah making america women
feel bad about not being perfect did you
hear what i said so they said come in
and talk to these guys
uh-huh so i went okay i'll come talk to
them so i go in and meet these guys
and they give me this whole book line
that's all lies
[Laughter]
it's not gonna be the tim allen show
we're not calling it the melon show it's
about both people
it's not about me it's about you you
know we've got to have somebody who
challenges him and is
as much a feminist as he is a
masculinist and it has to be an equal
struggle
because he'll seem abusive if she's not
as strong as he is he's going to seem
abusive
you know and we need that strength
coming from you to fight
that i'm perfectly happy being married
to a man who thinks that
pbs is something that women get once a
month you're in that meeting you take
that and you're like oh this is
what i want yeah what they told me that
was really important and kept
and kept in my mind through the entire
eight years of the show and what i think
is
crucial to the show is that their idea
of the show
which was this is why men and women
shouldn't live together
the whole concept of the show is this is
why we men and women really shouldn't
live together
but but what we're doing with the show
is how they can
there's got to be something in here you
can get rid of
yeah but i stayed married to it because
of the kids
when did you realize that you two would
have this
magical chemistry immediately i loved
him
i mean i was so happy to work again
after a year of not working and i came
in and
it was sad because the kids on the show
were terrified
when somebody gets i'd replaced fired
people before it wasn't my first time
and so i knew what it was like to come
on to a set where people are scared
because someone's been fired other
people everybody feels in danger
rick hadn't worked that much i mean rick
was you know an apartment manager and he
had done some rep theater but not a lot
um of course tim hadn't worked at all i
mean not much as an actor anyway
and so it was really just me and earl
who were really experienced actors
jonathan i think had worked more as a
kid than the other kids everybody's
really off everybody's just like
because they were one day away from when
they were supposed to take the show
i come in on a thursday friday was
supposed to be the taping day
and now overnight they've heard uh no
that's not what's happening now we're
now taping tuesday there's a new person
so everybody's just like tim bless his
heart is
very disappointed not to be kissing the
very beautiful francis fisher and
hanging out with clint eastwood anymore
and now he has big old lactating pat
come in
this was not his dream i just read this
survey
and said that some couples no matter how
busy they are
still make love five times a week
with each other i was nursing twins i
had to make a half gallon of milk a day
so i'm like 150 pounds or something and
i was not intending to work this soon
so that was like that for a while and
what was great was that the producers
were like we don't
i was like i have time to lose the
weight i don't want to work i
was like we don't care we don't care you
just look wherever you're like we don't
care
you look real we don't care that's the
thing you came to play
a real woman that's what i wanted
and then of course the tabloids turned
that into
this is my first experience with
tabloids oh man did i have an education
there
i thought you know just being a normal
person seeing them in the grocery store
i used to think well there must be smoke
at least
behind these stories right i mean they
must have something and they're coming
off of something
they just make everything up they come
from nowhere
i mean they said for instance about that
that the producers made me keep the
weight on i was like
how are they making me keep waiting on
do they come to my house and force feed
me
they're like don't you we're gonna no i
don't think so i don't have time to lose
the weight i don't have time to work
out when am i going to work out i don't
have time to work out when do you
realize that this show you're doing
you have a bona fide hit on your hands
the first time i really thought i was
going to be able to do this show get my
money
get out and be with my babies and that
was what i wanted so we do the pilot
you don't even look at me like that
i what if you were two speeds in
reversible
the night of the pilot i'm not
exaggerating we had
to wait as long as 13 seconds
for them to stop laughing before we
could say the next line i'm like and
what's going on in my mind is boy how
much do they pay these people to come
here and laugh like this
this is this is ridiculous this is the
most
ridiculous audience i have ever heard
i'm so sorry the grunting hairy egg
model was sold out
just once a day i almost wanted to turn
around again okay guys really this is
too much
back it off you know but i mean then i
would say line another 11 13 seconds
would go by
i mean it was like holy moly here come
come on calm down guys
so it was unbelievable but i mean i was
a huge success
that night so i go back to the dressing
room my husband's up there and i walk in
the dressing room and he goes well
welcome to the show you're going to be
doing for the next seven years
and i'm hearing you're getting the spot
next to roseanne so then i didn't know
how to react
because that was not really i mean yeah
you want to hit show and we were really
worried about
how we were going to send three kids to
college what is it about
jill taylor that people love so much
what did the [ __ ] have for breakfast
today you had cereal in an english
monster
this was the woman that you want to be
the primary thing i saw the most in the
mail
was are you looking through our windows
the things you and tim fight about are
just like our family
it was very gratifying to me because tim
and i worked
so hard and so did john pasquan who was
our first director
and who based everything we did on
behavior
sometimes when you look it makes me feel
less appealing you know like
um i lost a little something lost
anything you've gained
and was vigilant about this being about
the story about the behavior what do the
characters want what do the characters
need what are they looking for
we lost all three of our original
writers after the first two years
and it changed the dynamic for you
didn't it it was very difficult
but for you and those after those first
couple of seasons now
jill's not being the equal partner what
i try to always give these original
writers credit for
which they really deserve they taught
all the other writers in the writing
room
about story that that story has to rain
if you don't keep an original writer on
the whole eight years it's a huge
problem
there's nobody but the original writers
who really cares about it the way the
original writers do
and the other ones come in and it's a
good gig it's a hit show
it's a good gig to work on that hit show
but it's not their baby
eventually i would kind of go like i
don't think that's the way that i would
react and i
you know i do i just don't feel like
that's the way i would feel about this
this one counts we're keeping score i
thought you didn't want to keep score
oh is the great big bad bowling man
afraid his itty bitty wife is gonna beat
him i want to show you something from
the show cause speaking of the first
season
i think those first couple of years in
the show were the best we ever did
they've given us such a good time
slot and there's been such good press
and
and all my friends and my husbands and
everybody thinks the show is so terrific
i mean
it's a little hard not to buy into the
the what everyone's saying that the
show's to be a big hit do you remember
this to expect
success i'd already been through too
much of that you know
if you get a hit show it's not like
winning the lottery to have something
like home improvement and you'll never
will see that again
the audiences were so massive massive
we had what 33 million people you know
watching
occasionally we'd have like like when we
did the cancer show which by the way was
my idea my son had a big thyroid cancer
scare so the writers come to my house
like they would sometimes do
the beginning so we could talk about
ideas for the next year's
shows i said okay guys i know this may
sound
risky but um i had a big thyroid cancer
scare
this summer with henry and i think we
could get away with doing the big c
we could do a cancer show because goiter
is funny
and thyroid cancer is curable it doesn't
travel
it's something we could warn people
about that they could see you know i
think we could do this and it could be
you could find a way to make this funny
and also
warn people and we could maybe do a
semi-series show and actually get away
with doing cancer if we do that and then
they ended they got the
um ximena humanities award for it big
deal right um it ended up being a really
big deal and
and and it was awesome show and they
wrote a completely different story i
mean the story had nothing to do with
what happened with us
and it was a brilliant thing that they
wrote and that was one of your highest
rated episodes right 30 something
million people yeah
why do people still love the show today
here's one thing that they did
that last man standing does not do that
they did that is really smart
and and makes it live forever they would
not tie it
to anything going on politically at the
time they wouldn't tie it to any current
events
they wanted it to always sort of seem
eternal you never knew what was going on
in the world that we lived in
the only way that it could be tied to
the 90s was our clothes
and the hair it was subtle deer but i
did grasp it everything that we
dealt with in terms of marriage and
family and kids really
oh we're just sort of classic ongoing
deals
you know ongoing situations you know
ongoing things that are going on now
and it it still works today it does what
was it like reuniting with him to do
last minute what was that it was so
weird because you know he's never really
forgiven me for not wanting to do the
ninth year
and that was very awkward they tried to
get me to the ninth year the whole time
i was negotiating the eighth
and i had been saying no that whole time
there's not enough money in the world to
do the ninth year then they went to tim
and they said let's do it with dead jill
and then tim was like
i don't think we can do that so then he
went out and said
oh i think it's time to end home and
proof well duh
what was it like when you go back now
have you guys had nobody kissed and made
his nose out of joint because i you know
and it was hurt his feelings because you
know you're so
attached to to tim taylor he loved tim
taylor
he loved being tim taylor he loved tim
taylor's family
tim taylor was this heavily married man
with his great boys and great life
and so he wanted that show to go on
forever there was one part of him i
think
that just wanted to stay in that
marriage and have those kids and be in
this
fantasy life and that's why he has last
man standing because when that ended
he had to have some version of that to
keep going on your exchange with tim
on last man standing is very funny
interesting but revealing at the same
time
have we met before you do look vaguely
familiar
it was really fun the first one was so
fun people would say oh your chemistry
is still there
i'm like it is i i don't know you know
you're not aware of whether you have
chemistry or not
i didn't know whether we would still
have it or not i was so
nervous because i hadn't done a sitcom
in
something like 11 or 12 years or more i
i don't i just hadn't done any sitcom
work
in years i've been doing drama this
reminds me of talking to my husband
will you go back this season no i don't
think i should i gotta meet one of my
sons for lunch
[Music]
i don't think we've met dandy you're
looking familiar
yeah randy how's it going i want to show
you another clip oh yeah
that's my short hair phase everybody
hated
my short hair my twins were only three
months old and i really wasn't
ready to go back to work full-time but i
really thought it would just be a pilot
and
i could make a bunch of money really
fast in five days and then i'd be out of
it
and no i had no idea even then you were
like i had no clue
none none i mean that first year or two
of the show
was so fun to do the show and it was so
fun to have the twins
and the twins were like the mascot on
the set they were all
everybody was so kind to them when they
were three they had to stop coming to
the set because they had to go to
nursery school
and i was never getting to see henry
very much and so
then i had this thing of not really
being able to see my kids anymore
and that started being really hard to be
a lot
now that you look back right you you
have these
grown children who turned out great you
have this amazing
you have grandkids you have a grandchild
well now i face all the things i did
wrong as a parent
and and i'm living with that and my kids
are living with that it was
really hard for me to split focus it was
a lot of heaviness
i lost my parents i lost my career
because i quit
after west wing i had teenagers that
were now spinning out
i had three teenagers all spinning out
at once and
and then i'd lost my parents and i felt
like blessed my sisters
and um and my relationship broke up
and i was in menopause and
um i everything hit it once
and i just i quit i couldn't quite
enough i got up believe it or not
i got up to 170 pounds during this time
i was so depressed
i just quit and then i just had to go
through this grief
it was really i can't even say it's
depression i went to a shrink i was
grieving
seriously grieving but now you're it
seems like you've found such a happy
place i find my way out of that
yeah but it wasn't easy and it was hard
and it was hard on my kids and we all
went through a hard time together
it's better now i have always kind of
tried to like
put them first that's always been the
case they were first
so the career had to take the back seat
because if somebody had to make them
first
most important job you'll ever have yeah